-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Welcome, everybody.
Well, guys, Russia's invasion
of Ukraine continued today.
In a controversial
new interview,
former President Trump said
Vladimir Putin is very savvy
and called his strategy genius.
[ Laughter ]
Keep in mind, Trump also used
the word "savvy" and "genius"
to describe
McDonald's dollar menu, so...
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, I'm not sure you want
to be called a genius by the guy
who clogged
the White House toilet
with classified documents.
[ Laughter ]
"Just flush it."
Well, everyone's
been talking about this.
Buckingham Palace announced
that Queen Elizabeth has COVID
and is dealing
with mild symptoms.
When asked how she was feeling,
the Queen said,
"Well, we're not talking about
Prince Andrew, so a lot better."
[ Laughter ]
So far, the Queen said
the worst symptom
is Prince Charles coming in
every four seconds
to see how she's doing.
[ Laughter ]
"You doing okay, Mom?
Okay.
I don't think you need
that booster, mum.
I think you can really tough
your way through this one."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
This year, the Oscars
are planning to pre-record
some awards before the ceremony
and air them
during the live broadcast.
[ Audience groans ]
Even more insulting, before
the awards are presented,
the announcer will say,
"And now the categories
nobody cares about."
[ Laughter ]
If they really want
to shorten the broadcast,
maybe just skip the part
where someone explains
what an actor is.
[ Laughter ]
"An actor acts."
Some business news --
I read that Peloton
had a secret initiative
called Project Tinman
where they hid rust on bikes
that were sent out to customers.
And somehow
this has been the best news
about Peloton all year.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually good news
because it means
Big didn't die
of a heart attack.
He died of tetanus.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, come on.
He looked healthy.
Now I get it.
Hey, I heard that IHOP
just launched its first
plant-based sandwich at one
location in New York City.
Yeah, it's for all the people
who sit down at breakfast like,
"Do I want the fudge pancakes
or the mung-bean sandwich?
Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
Can't be fun eating a vegan
sandwich while the person
across from you sprays whipped
cream on his breakfast.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of plant-based food,
Kraft Heinz just announced
that it wants to make
plant-based
Oscar Mayer hot dogs.
[ Audience groans ]
Oscar Mayer said they care about
the environment,
then they kept driving across
the country in a giant hot dog
that gets 3 miles a gallon.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is going viral.
A news reporter in Ohio
was out in the field reporting
when he was surprised by someone
he knows pretty well.
Take a look at this.
-It's because of --
This is my mom.
Hold on.
-Uh-oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hi, baby!
-[ Laughing ]
-I'm trying to work right now,
and you over there
calling my phone.
This is Deangelo.
You can say hi.
-Hi, Deangelo!
-And don't be holding up traffic
because you got cars behind you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's not bad.
Then his mom threw it in reverse
and was like,
"I got some breaking news!
Mommy loves you!"
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- a new study
found that dinosaurs
actually used to get
respiratory infections.
I guess that explains
the latest trailer
I just saw for
the "Jurassic World" movie.
Watch this.
♪♪
-[ Cough ]
-Coming this summer...
-[ Coughing, groans ]
-...experience
the epic conclusion.
-[ Coughing ]
-[ Clears throat ]
-"Jurassic World: Dominion."
In -- [ Clears throat ] --
theaters -- [ Coughs ] --
June 10th.
[ Coughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now I --
Now I understand that.
And, finally, parking here
in New York City can be hard,
but I think this guy
found a new way to do it.
Look at this.
Look at this --
[ Laughter ]
Look at that photo.
Oh, my gosh.
You know
a third car drove by like,
"I bet I could
squeeze in between..."
[ Laughter ]
It'll be even weirder
in nine months
when the Toyota
gives birth to a smart car.